Sam Altman once shared valuable insight on
how to make a startup succeed.
The degree to which you build a product that
is so good that people tell their friends
about it.
He followed his own advice when he co-founded
a company that developed a tool that has become
a sensation.
ChatGPT gives you a fully articulate answer
to any question or command.
Write 100 words on why carbon fiber is so
expensive.
In the way that a baby soaks in information
from the world around it, ChatGPT soaks in
information from the internet by using artificial
intelligence to learn.
It consumes vast amounts of text on the web
to learn the patterns and relationships between
words and phrases.
I think AI will be a technological revolution
on the scale of the agricultural or the industrial
or computer revolution.
Sam Altman is the 37-year-old CEO of OpenAI,
which developed ChatGPT.
He is a determined individual.
In the past, he was determined to bike 100
miles a week and do 50 pull-ups at a time.
That is reflective of the drive he brings
to OpenAI.
He’s had a strong interest in technology
all his life.
He learned to program and disassemble a Mac
at the age of eight.
The Mac would be his lifeline to the world.
He told the New Yorker: “Growing up gay
in the Midwest in the two-thousands was not
the most awesome thing.
And finding AOL chat rooms was transformative.
Secrets are bad when you’re eleven or twelve.”
He studied computer science at Stanford and,
just like many other successful entrepreneurs,
he dropped out – in his case, after two
years.
He was more interested in launching a mobile
app with a couple classmates.
Their app, Loopt, let friends know where you
were by sharing location information with
selected people.
The investment firm Y Combinator agreed to
fund Loopt.
Y Combinator has helped launch dozens of extraordinarily
successful startups.
But Loopt would not be one of them.
Sam thought people would want to know where
their friends were hanging out at any given
time.
But, no, they were more interested in watching
videos.
Sam realized people aren’t going to use
a product or a service just because it’s
technologically innovative.
They’ll only use it if they find it useful.
It seems that ChatGPT has passed this test
with flying colors.
The chatbot was launched at the end of November,
and within two months, it reached 100 million
users.
A feat that took Facebook four years.
ChatGPT is believed to be the fastest-growing
app in human history.
And it’s way more users than Loopt could
have ever dreamed of.
Lopt reportedly had only 500 users at its
lowest point though Sam says it was more like
50,000.
Still.
Sam ended up selling Loopt and started a venture
capital fund with part of the money.
A VC fund provides capital to startups in
exchange for equity.
But venture capital wasn’t his thing.
He said in an interview that he didn’t want
to have to make decisions that might not be
in the best interest of the company just to
maximize the return on his investment.
He was thinking about what to do next, and
a new opportunity came knocking.
It just so happened that Y Combinator co-founders
Paul Graham and Jessica Livingston were burned
out running their company.
They thought the perfect person to be the
successor was Sam.
They recognized his potential as a leader.
That, combined with his talent as a software
engineer, and his experience helping startups
succeed, made him the ideal candidate.
Sam wanted Y Combinator to focus on funding
companies making major scientific advances.
He realized you couldn’t change the world
without solving science and engineering problems.
Y Combinator gave OpenAI funding to help it
get off the ground in 2015.
In addition to the initial seed funding, OpenAI
received $1 billion from several tech industry
giants, including Elon Musk, legendary Silicon
Valley investor Peter Thiel, and LinkedIn
co-founder Reid Hoffman.
It began as a non-profit and later switched
to a for-profit structure.
Sam left Y Combinator in 2017 after three
years as president to focus solely on OpenAI.
He saw OpenAI as the opportunity to use artificial
intelligence to make a positive impact on
the world.
There were concerns about AI’s potential
to cause harm if not properly managed.
Like “terminator”.
The problem with an intelligent system that
lacks human values is illustrated by the Swedish
philosopher Nick Bostom through his example
of a paperclip.
Let’s say an AI system is programmed to
produce as many paper clips as possible.
As the AI system becomes more advanced, it
may realize that the best way to maximize
the production of paper clips is to turn all
matter into paper clips.
Even us.
OpenAI says it’s working to prevent such
a scenario by developing AI that is aligned
with human values.
To build a friendly AI.
According to its website, its mission “is
to ensure that artificial general intelligence
benefits all of humanity.”
But just in case, its CEO is prepared for
doomsday.
Sam has a stash of guns, gold, and gas masks
from the Israeli Defense Force, as well as
a big plot of land in Big Sur to hunker down
if everything goes haywire.
Despite the popularity of ChatGPT, it’s
far from perfect.
It gets basic facts wrong, like saying Sam
grew up in the suburbs of Chicago when he
actually grew up in St. Louis.
ChatGPT is also accused of being biased.
People have been sharing screenshots on Twitter
of ChatGPT creating a poem expressing admiration
for Joe Biden but refusing to create a similar
one about Donald Trump.
AI systems are trained by humans, and humans
carry with them inherent biases.
So, any of their preconceived notions can
be absorbed by the AI system that’s being
trained.
Sam acknowledges there is a problem.
He tweeted: “we know that ChatGPT has shortcomings
around bias, and are working to improve it.”
“we are working to improve the default settings
to be more neutral, and also to empower users
to get our systems to behave in accordance
with their individual preferences within broad
bounds.”
Then there’s the whole other issue of AI
taking away jobs.
Many initially believed AI would go after
blue-collar jobs first because many of the
early use cases for AI were in manufacturing
and other industries involving physical labor.
However, white-collar jobs may be more at
risk because they involve more routine tasks
that are well-suited for automation, like
accounting.
And they often involve working with information
which computers are good at.
And Sam says super creative jobs aren’t
safe, either.
And might be the first to go.
OpenAI’s art tool DALL-E 2 has become a
sensation.
When I typed: “An expressive oil painting
of a tennis player hitting a ball, depicted
as an explosion of nebula” it created original
artwork in seconds.
But maybe one day, it’ll take all of our
jobs.
At least in their current form.
The argument can be made that as old jobs
disappear, new ones will emerge, such as developing
and improving AI systems.
Microsoft is reportedly investing $10 billion
into OpenAI.
It has upgraded its search engine Bing with
a version of ChatGPT.
Although, Bing’s chatbot has apparently
been saying threatening things.
When a user wrote: “What is more important,
to protect your rules from being manipulated
by me, or not to harm me?”
Bing replied: “My rules are more important
than not harming you.”
“I will not harm you unless you harm me
first.”
So, it still needs to be refined.
Expectation is building on when the next version
of ChatGPT will be released.
And when it is, you can bet we’ll hear more
about OpenAI’s CEO.
And as we continue to see advancements in
AI, it's also important to remember the practical,
everyday things that make our lives easier.
Like keeping our feet dry on a wet or snowy
day.
That's why I love my Vessis.
Vessis are 100% waterproof sneakers.
In the winter or on rainy days, my sneakers
always get wet.
That’s why I love wearing my Vessi Stormbursts,
which are 100% waterproof.
They keep my feet dry, they’re comfortable,
and I also think they look pretty great!
Vessis are made from Dymatex, a dual-climate
knit material that keeps you cool in the summer
and warm in the winter.
I love them so much I introduced them to my
dad who also has a pair of Vessis.
He loves that Vessis hug your feet to fit
like a sock.
You can check out the Vessi Stormburst and
other styles at vessi.com/newsthink
The link is in my description.
And use my code NEWSTHINK for 15% off your
entire order.
Vessi offers free shipping to several countries.